comment ont commencé ces agressions
c'est violent c'est un test pour vous je
me souviens d'image donc je veux pas
dire exactement comment une quand est-ce
que ça a commencé comment ça s'est passé
j'ai des flashs l'intervalle j'ai pas de
mois ou d'années enfin voilà et donc
j'ai exactement les scènes je les vois
donc ça c'est donc déjà je suis dans un
milieu très aisé
je suis issu d'un milieu très aisé une
famille nombreuse donc des employés de
maison
beaucoup de monde autour de nous et
voilà donc
il s'agit de deux enfants un peu plus
âgés que moi donc c'est un enfant ce
n'est pas un adulte et donc bon revers 4
ont peut-être ça commence par les
attouchements voilà une pénétration
digitale puis avec des objets etc
voilà donc je me vois je suis je sais
que c'est moi je me vois je suis comme
en dehors de mon corps et je vois les
scènes
donc on sait exactement maintenant
comment ça s'appelle que c'est de la
dissociation mais moi je n'avais pas
connaissance dans une forme de
protection en fait voilà c'est le
cerveau qui met en place ce mécanisme
pour pour supporter ce qui se passe
donc ça dure des années et je ne sais
pas l'arrêter voilà est ce que parce que
ça dure pendant dix ans oui est-ce que à
un moment vous en parler à quelqu'un
d'autre dans le cercle familial ou en
dehors du cercle familial
alors j'ai déjà donc un passage fait
assez éprouvant c'est
[Musique]
c'est dans la cave et donc ce jour là
dedans la saur sur une bouteille est bon
bien sûr que je vais avoir du sens dans
ma culotte et donc la nounou va voir
cela et il va me dire je vais en parler
à maman pas c'est pas normal
voilà voilà et la nounou
je sais pas voilà moi j'ai jamais eu
d'écho de après bon l'âge de donc à une
rédaction où j'exprime un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé ce jour là que j'ai que
pour dater je parle la rédaction parce
qu'elle permet de dater à peu près quand
tu sais ce que ça s'est passé puisque
ses antérieurs
j'ai dix ans quand j'écris ma rédaction
donc voilà mais là quelqu'un était moi
mais ce que vous faites quelque chose
voilà s'aperçoivent mais moi je n'ai non
mais moi je suis contente qu'elle veut
qu'elle va parler et puis se passe rien
mais voilà donc ça m'a enfermée encore
plus dans le silence voilà puisque
personne ne réagit pas quand est-ce que
vous malgré votre jeune âge puis
j'imagine que vous étiez terrorisé enfin
complètement sous l'emprise de ces
situations vous tourner quand même vers
quelqu'un d'autre de la famille ou en
dehors des familles non non pas là pas
du tout à ce moment là pas du tout et
pourquoi selon vous pourquoi selon vous
à ce moment là justement qu'on ne
trouvait pas d'échappatoire ou bien
quelqu'un qui parlait c'est ce qu'ont pu
d'abord au débat au départ je suis trop
petit pour comprendre en fait donc je
laisse faire
là le fait que la nounou disent qu'elle
va en parler maman parce que c'est pas
normal je sais même pas moi la normalité
moi je la connais pas la normal donc
qu'elle nie qu'elle va en parler à maman
parce que ce n'est pas normal et qu'il
ne sort pas sans rien pour moi je suis
remis dans cette normalité la cua mois
pour moi voilà c'est comme ça que ça se
passe que vous aviez même entre tours et
10 ans contre 4 4 entre 4 et 14 ans ne
court pas tant qu'elle atteint 14 ouais
et moment vous si vous permettez à
quelques mots vous êtes libérés ou bien
vous avez réalisé
et puisque ce qui s'était passé était
grave parce que ça prend beaucoup de
temps justement pour que ça puisse ce
matin à bâle en lari expliqué que alors
là ça me faire c'est une cinquantaine
d'années pour que je comprenne vraiment
tout ça voilà donc c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre ce que j'ai pas d' amnésie
post-traumatique donc se sait qui c'est
je connais je vois les actes et tout
mais la gravité des choses le l'affectif
et c'est là c'est c'est la catastrophe
il va falloir vraiment un grand travail
pour que j'arrive à ça le train
comportant quelques instants pour
expliquer ce que c'est que le voile
amnésie post-traumatique c'est que dans
certains cas les victimes aussi par
mécanisme de défense et ou d'oubli où
elle a eu refoule à tel point laquelle
on a l'impression de n'avoir jamais vécu
ce qu'elles ont subi mais c'est pas
votre cas non c'est pas moi j'ai
toujours su ce qui s'est passé et se
séparer de camp que vous vous dites les
choses donc à 14 ans j'ai déjà je lui
dis il faut arrêter voilà là il faut
arrêter ce n'est pas lui qui
spontanément s'arrête c'est vous qui ont
été arrêtés j'ai dit que je lui dis
qu'il faut s'arrêter mais mais lui il va
me faire chanter et le chantage il c'est
incroyable il va dire je vais le dire à
maman je vais dire à maman tout ce que
tu as fait c'est moi qui suit la vie
d'un bébé doc l'at il est habilité gelé
en moi déjà depuis des années et je et
bien sûr que la samah câble donc voilà
donc ça ne s'arrête pas quoi voilà et
moi je vais avoir ce poids-là de ne
jamais avoir été capable de faire
arrêter
voilà donc je suis encore plus coupable
mais honte et la culpabilité sont
énormes en moins à la fête cette
perversité un marché vous ressenti ça
c'était sûr que j'étais sûr voilà oui
c'est vrai pas gta c'est vrai t'es
catastrophique voilà et quand on subit
des choses aussi graves
aussi jeune on imagine quand même que ça
des effets très fort sur une sur une
fillette est ce que vous aviez des jets
pas des troubles du comportement ou des
problèmes particuliers alors bon à
l'école c'était brillante donc ça pas eu
d'impact sur l'école au contraire je me
réfugiais mois dans les mathématiques
puisque
j'ai fait des études de mathématiques
c'était vraiment au contraire en mon
havre de paix j'étais détaché de tout le
monde grâce aux études c'était très bien
donc ça a été ma chance en fait l'école
vont à l'école et à l'école oui c'était
la chance mais autrement les cauchemars
voilà alors et cauchemars mortes et plus
de 50 ans un hayon les la nuit coin
voilà c'était vraiment les cauchemars où
les fêtes encore non non c'est
finalement c'était c'était non mais
parce que parce que j'ai fait un an
qu'on travaille pour arriver à justement
la confiance à tout ça faut savoir que
ce phénomène-là d'insister quand même
exponentiel j'en discutais en cours tout
à l'heure au téléphone avec laurent
boyer qui un policier que nous puisque
nous avons accueilli beaucoup avec les
papillons podium je discute avec lui
tout à l'heure des dispositifs qu'ils
entendent mettre en place justement pour
faire parler les enfants parce que la
problématique c'est de parler à le sujet
et il me dit que c'est exponentiel c'est
à dire que dans les collèges les lycées
les écoles primaires où il veut mettre
en place des fameuses boîtes aux lettres
pour que les gosses laisse quelque chose
près d'abord il rencontre et là on va
pouvoir en discuter tout à l'heure parce
que les lois du sénat c'est sympathique
mais après concrètement sur le terrain
comment ça se fait ça l'agacé
l'éducation nationale là dessus est
bloquée j'espère que blanc caire nous
entende ce soir adrien d'attaquer le
sait le ministre c'est une catastrophe
il faut qu'on libère alors la route dans
ces enfants parce que ce que disait très
justement madame c'est une catastrophe
on s'est reparlé les enfants pour dire
exactement ce qui se passe
ouais c'est très compliqué par aborder
ce cas tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
dire qu'en effet isabelle parle
évidemment son nom mais au nom de
beaucoup de personnes est-ce qu'on a
rassemblé quelques chiffres fait environ
un français sur dix auraient été
victimes d'inceste et 10% des enfants
c'est la paix dans un colossal 26% des
français connaissent au moins une
personne victime d'inceste dans leur
entourage
chaque année plus de 130000 filles et
35000 garçons subissent des viols ou des
tentatives de viol mais en majorité
incestueux donc elle le double problème
du violet et de l'inceste un agresseur
sur quatre est mineure est en effet
comme vous le soulignez bruno ces
chiffres ne font que monter depuis 2009
et contrairement isabelle quatre
victimes sur dix rapports des épisodes
d'amnésie et pour un tiers d'entre elles
ces épisodes d'amnésie ont duré plus de
vingt ans alors après et à une autre
étape très importante c'est qu'une
dizaine d'années après que ces faits de
viol et d'inceste et cc vous faites un
divin une dizaine les dents je croyais
que c'était à 25 ans vous l'aviez fait
oh non non non non
non non moi moi moi à 20 h à 21 ans je
me marie je fais des études je fais des
études de maths donc mon mari s'en va à
la naissance de mon premier fils ses 24
ans et là j'achète ma part je parle à ma
mère là j'ose le dire à ma mère de 24
ans voilà jose le lui dire et le silence
voilà deux votes elle me dit pas elle me
dit pas c'est pas vrai elle me dit pas
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes tu es
folle n'ont rien mais non je ne le
savais pas ses 24 ans vous avez juste à
vous construire tout seul ou faire un
faisan suivant déjà vous dire comment
suis je veux maintenant ce qui est
sidérant dans ce que vous racontez c'est
le parallèle qu'on peut voir avec le
livre de techno lab lui parler parce que
elle recommande la mairie laquelle avec
avec son frère ou son frère lui dit tu
verras quand on leur dira ils ne le
diront pas mais il s'en foutront ouais
je ne sais pas mais vous pensez qu'elle
ne savait ou quoi moi je n'ai jamais
pensé qu'elle le savait c'était trop
compliqué pour moi trop douloureux je
pensais que ma mère pouvait savoir mais
bien sûr après avec des adp trente ans
plus tard
cinquante ans plus tard avec la thérapie
et tout mais j'ai bien sûr moi la malade
ma psy m'a dit mais enfin isabelle ou
lui avaient dit oui mais voilà elle le
sait elle le sait mais moi je voudrais
que quand même on revienne un peu sur
cette scène parce que j'ai quand même du
mal à imaginer que vous fassiez une
révélation ou pas d'ailleurs peut-être
le savent et elles mais vous dit quelque
chose d'extrêmement important d'accès
mais extrêmement graves à votre mère
elle garde un mutisme total elle vaut
regarder elle ne répond pas du tout oui
elle ne revient jamais sur le sujet non
moi je reviens petit peu de temps en
temps je suis revenu sur le sujet
lorsque
il ya eu le livre de
la belle file de bontems y avait paru
c'était les années 80 ou encore une
histoire de livres dont les sondages oui
bien sûr c'est bien parce que vous vous
reconnaissez dans l'histoire bon vous
dites bon et bien on en avait discuté et
et ma mère marc m'a répondu que c'était
d'abord vraiment pas bien de dénoncer
quelqu'un après sa mort
ce qui n'était pas là pour se défendre
déjà hop voilà donc c'est pas bien donc
deuxièmement à ces affaires là ça se
règle en famille et troisièmement dans
notre famille il ne s'est jamais rien
passé c'est que la réponse ou 20 perd
donc comment vous l'expliquez ça avec le
recul d'imaginer que vous y avez
réfléchi
ben oui bah oui mais je sais c'est
difficile de répondre parce que je vais
après je suis obligé de deux de dire qui
c'est quoi cette routine green il faut
chercher des appuis chez d'autres gens
de la famille une autre voie non non non
je sais c'est que ces types d'un mur en
face à certains misent à manquer ce qui
fait oui qu'est ce qui fait qu'à
l'époque qu'est ce qui aurait pu vous
aider à l'époque à 3 ans à 5 ans à 10
ans qu'est ce qui aurait pu vous aider
c'est très important parce qu'on se
demande ce qui pourrait aider les
victimes présentées les futures victimes
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils auraient aidé
qu'est ce qui n'existait pas à l'époque
qui pourrait déjà à l'époque
il y avait quand même une certaine les
mentalités étaient quand même bien pire
qu'aujourd'hui
voilà donc ça il faut voir le contexte
c'était quand tu parles d année 110
d'interdire de l'interdît enfin voilà
donc voila moi j'étais là dedans kouassi
d'où le tout donc c'est ça ils ont
ensuite vous étiez plus jeune nouvelle
peut être un livre sort enfin vous
permet de parler un autre adulte mais
quand même
ben j'ai changé je suis pas que
quelqu'un dans les sortes le livre de la
belle-fille de mon temps je sais je sais
pas oui un livre ma vie jean part je
sais voilà c'est ça oui bien sûr bien
sûr j'aurai maintenant qu'on en vienne
aux livres et on va répondre à la
question de bernard parce qu'il ya un
scandale dans le scandale d'abord
qu'est-ce qui vous voilà qui ce qui vous
fait passer à l'acte de l'écriture
arrivons donc c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce que j'ai fait j'ai cru
faire comme il vraiment bien et c'est
pour ça que je suis heureuse de
témoigner pour dire que c'était pas la
solution ça ne marche pas j'ai essayé de
mettre tout ça de côté
donc j'ai mis tout ça de côté et j'ai
construit ma vie et j'ai fait une
carrière j'ai un doctorat de match j'ai
fait une carrière dans ibm donc dans une
multinationale j'ai eu des enfants et de
marie bon évidemment là c'était plus
chaotique le comprendre mais bon voilà
non mais mais c'était quand même dans la
construction je pensais bâtir quelque
chose dont on bâtit pas sur du sable
donc cesser c'est pas terrible quand
même donc ce que vous dites voilà ce
qu'il faut pas le garder pour soi et
bien non parce que ça paraît quand vous
êtes mal construit comme je l'étais si
vous restez comme ça mal construits ben
les relations avec d autres sont
particulières les signes les gens que
vous recherchez sont particuliers enfin
tout ça tout ça est compliqué ce que
vous voulez dire par là qu on cherche
des gens particulier quand on a subi on
cherche sais pas je ne changerai pas
trop d'ambition soyons vague vous savez
une autre figure familiale où l'on
cherche à nous équivalent mais c'est à
dire qu'on ne comprend pas trop l'amour
c'est compliqué lamoura comme relais
vos parents enfin tout cas votre famille
nous a donné un amour qui est très très
particulier qui est très toxique et
l'amour et c'est plutôt quelque chose de
toxines
voilà justement question très difficile
à poser mais jamais vous la posez pas je
suis convaincu que beaucoup veulent vous
la posez la sexualité pour un homme pour
une femme c'est important d'en donner
avis ça va oui est-ce que vous pensez
que malgré tout ça vous avez eu un
épanouissement dans votre sexualité
normale après ou pas pas du tout non
mais c'est à dire que moi je m'en
foutais complètement nettoyé qu'on sait
c'est c'était pas un problème
voilà c'est ça c'était ben oui je ne
sais pas voilà voilà
ni à ce traumatisme chez forcément
forcément on était dans la dissociation
pendant des années donc tout son gré de
notre corps c'est pas voilà mérite une
chose qui est importante de ce que dit
madame dans les années où ça lui arrive
il n'y avait pas toutes les aides il ya
il ya quand même beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faites depuis
malgré que ce soit exponentielle la
problématique il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites beaucoup de parents
qui ont l'air de savoir des dispositifs
quand j'étais cet après midi avec le
mini série intérieur à discuter sur les
sur les structures des unités de
matières traitées par monsieur quitter
oui l'ami d'inquiéter tu vas et encore
une fois la police est là pour ça aussi
longtemps gendarmerie police etc
il ya une mise en place des salles qui
ont été copiés sur un modèle canadien
qu'il est celle de mélanie pour
accueillir des enfants justement qui
sont violées qui sont tripoter on c'est
vrai ça des choses object et ennemi
c'est rien dire là-dessus ira bien
travaillé je pense avec la gendarmerie
d'ailleurs il y en a une quarantaine de
centres en france comme ça qu'ils qui
travaillent assidûment
mais encore une fois la problématique
est exponentielle et ça c'est une vraie
un vrai sujet donc il faut essayer de
faire parler les gamins mais après il
faut s'appuyer sur les associations
on parle des papillons bien sorti le
savoir où les joints et je me posais la
question sur le pardon sur le livre je
suis livré ensuite on continue jeunes
étaient décidés à faire ce livre
pourquoi je ne sais pas une décision
jamais pensé écrire j'ai une carrière
scientifique donc j'en étais je n'étais
pas là dedans du tout et puis donc
mon deuxième mari bon ben c'est vrai
c'est encore une fois l'assassin il ya
une rupture et donc j'ai 54 ans 55 ans
hélas ce que j'ai vécu là physiquement
c'est c'est incroyable et là c'est
quelque chose qui se connaît bien aussi
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment là vous
revivez tout ce que vous avez vécu à
dire que je rentrais chez moi j'avais la
déchirure qui sait tout qu'il
s'échappait de la déchirure cette
sensation là bon c'était pas vrai mais
que cette sensation de revenir vraiment
voilà vous voulez le viol c'est ça ce
qu'on appelle revivre le viol en fait je
n'ai pas compris ça mais j'avais
vraiment l'impression que toutes mes
entrailles s'échapper de mon ventre et
sans arrêt ça devenait insupportable
donc j'avais à la rupture j'avais
consulté un médecin parce que je voulais
dormir savait plus à dormir kim qui a
compris heureusement voilà alors là j'ai
eu un médecin qui a compris qu'ils
avaient quelque chose et qui m'a envoyé
chez la thérapeute d'en face j'ai entamé
une thérapie que j'ai refusé d'ailleurs
au départ parce que je n'avais pas pensé
d'avoir aucun problème
voilà c'est ça l'a vraiment le déni le
plus beau je n'avais aucun problème
quand elle me dit parler - de votre
enfance unis on va passer là dessus
voilà donc là elle me dit je peux vous
aider
moi j'y crois pas une minute mais rien
n'est sûr mon problème mon mari est
parti point c'est tout cas là c'est tout
et donc est donc je laisse un peu tombé
tout est là je vais je sais pas pourquoi
je vais amener un ami là où j'habitais
petit voilà donc lui se met à sonner
il est complètement fou il sonne à la
porte et on rentre dans cette ville a
conduit la ve somptueuse au bord de la
mer et la vieille dame c'est une vieille
dame nous fait nous fais mes parents
bien sûr n'habite plus la divina depuis
30 ans voilà ou 40 ans chez plus c'est
comptant 40 elles 40 ans
voilà et donc elle me fait visiter elle
nous fait rentrer je vais à val étage
donc déjà c'est bonjour voilà les
souvenirs au départ ça va on va les
étages et je ne vois plus la chambre la
chambre
voilà et là je me suis mise alors je
suis folle là j'ai mis en doute toutes
ces images que j'avais une bombe et là
je suis folle et puis en fait elle mais
elle était fière montrent qu'ils avaient
a brandi la chambre parentale et qu'ils
avaient absorbé la voilà la raison
le seul hic juste voilà allait cesser
d'exister
et là je rentre chez moi bon lui s'en va
et mettez loin et j'en suis moi et là je
me mets à écrire en quatre mois j'ai
écrit le premier livre que j'écris donc
en 2012
donc j'ai j'ai écrit et au fur et à
mesure que j'écrivais je pensais pas
écrire ça en plus
je pensais j'ai écrit ma vie voilà c'est
tout et puisqu il nous reste quelques
secondes avant la coupure pour répondre
à l'interrogation de bernard tout à
l'heure il se trouve que vous avez été
condamné par pour ce livre alors la
france
ça mérite une explication non mais c'est
normal
mon livre donc j'ai écrit et là je suis
accompagné avec ma psy qui qui qui me
qui m'aide à prendre la décision de
publier ce livre en mon nom j'ai donc
publier ce livre en mon nom propre
voilà donc mon nom propre il ya les noms
de tout le monde mais il ya tout voilà
et donc j'ai pas le droit de faire ça
j'ai pris cette décision sachant très
bien que j'étais hors la loi parce que
les inscrivait les faits sont prescrits
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire ça non
j'ai fait ça en connaissance de cause
voilà j'étais c'était ma vie j'étais en
train de mourir je voulais me
l'approprier